turin's glory days as an automaker town
have all but faded
the test track for new vehicles used to
be on the roof of the lingotto fiat
plant the building is now a convention
center complex with hotels in a museum
the squares of the old city centre used
to be parking lots now they're
pedestrian zones
the municipal government is trying to
market turin as a center of culture
architecture and design
this striking hall used to serve as a
car showroom for fiat now it's going to
be part of a new university campus
there's been a urban transformation in
terms of
new infrastructure in terms of restoring
of past industrial sites in order to
bring the city from a new perspective
which is
mostly focused over innovation culture
and knowledge economy and in particular
to put torino inside the university city
inside the europe there are already some
100 000 students in turin over 10
percent of the population but the number
is going to increase
the project is aimed to locate a new
public library here in the main pavilion
which is designed by the nervi
architecture to restore the theater
which is now still located here
and to promote the new student rooms for
teaching activity and for faculty here
in the underground pavilion but in this
time of austerity it's proving hard for
turin to come up with the funding for
this hundred million euro project even
so the city offers plenty of
opportunities for young entrepreneurs
like marco guy his industry association
considers turin a fertile place for
business development
young italians have a lot of know-how
creativity and innovative potential
this is expressed in the made in italy
brand which represents a strong
entrepreneurial tradition
and growth is picking up due to their
networking ability both at home and
abroad
large industrial corporations like prima
industry feel they're well positioned
even with less business coming in from
fiat
the parts supply industry in piedmont
still remains very important with 900
companies some 90 000 dependents and
revenues of 18 billion euros only 40
percent of that comes from fiat already
60 percent of our production is for
other customers
it seems despite fiat's retreat and a
prolonged recession turin is
transforming itself into a modern
multifaceted metropolis